We've already talked
about kinetic energy
for an object that's
rotating and translating.
Let's take, again, a
simple object like a wheel.
Center of mass is
moving, and we want
to consider this is a bunch
of point-like particles,
th Jth particle with mass MJ,
and a position vector RCMJ.
And now what we'd like to do
is, what is the angular momentum
of this about some point P?
And we're going to do the
same type of decomposition
that we've been
doing right along.
Let's draw the vector RJ.
This is the vector from
the point P to the object.
Here's the vector capital R,
and there's the vector RCMJ.
And our same vector
addition, R plus RCMJ.
j Now let's calculate
the angular momentum
about the point
P. Now just let's
recall two facts about the
center of mass reference frame
that we've already used.
The first is that the sum of
the velocities, the momentum
in the center of mass
reference frame is zero,
and if you integrate this
equation in just exactly
the same way, if you added
up the mass times each
of the position
vectors, that's MJ,
MJ, in the center of mass
frame, that's also zero.
So we've used this when we
talked about kinetic energy.
Now we're going to consider
both of these results.
So recall that angular
momentum about a point
is the sum of the vector from
the point, cross-product MJ,
times the velocity BJ.
Now we can also use our
law of addition velocities,
VJ is V plus the
VCMJ, and so now
we're going to have to
do both substitutions.
That's why this calculation is
a little bit more complicated.
We have R plus RCMJ,
cross MJ times capital
D. That is the velocity
of the center of mass
with respect to the
ground frame plus VCMJ.
Now we have four terms
in the cross-product,
and this time we'll
write them all out.
So the first term is the sum
over J of R cross MJ capital D.
The second term is,
we'll take this one,
and we'll cross with that one.
But because MJ is just a scalar,
I'm going to pull it in front.
So that's MJ, RCMJ, and V is the
same for every single particle
in the object.
Remember, V is just the
velocity of one reference frame
with respect to the other.
So I can pull that out, cross
V. And you're already noticing
that this term will be zero.
The next term is
when I take R cross
MJVJ, V center of
mass, J, summed over J,
that's JR cross MJ, VCMJ.
But again, remember that
R is the same vector.
It's just from P to
the center of mass,
so I didn't need to
put the sum here.
I can pull R out of the sum
and I have my sum like that.
And again, you're probably
noticing that this term is zero
and our final term is
RCMJ cross MJ VCMJ.
So our final term is sum
R, RCMJ cross MJ VCMJ.
Now from these two
conditions, one and two,
both of these two
terms are zero.
And that's the power of using
the center of mass reference
frame.
So LP, now let's look
at the first term.
Here, R is the same
for every particle,
V is the same for
every particle,
when we're summing
over the mass,
we're just getting
the total mass,
so the first piece
is R cross M total V.
And this last piece is precisely
the definition of the angular
momentum of the Jth particle
in the center of mass frame.
So that's the sum
over J of LCMJ,
because RCM cross MVJ R
cross, say whatever speed this
is in the center of mass frame,
it could be that sum VCMJ.
BJ minus capital V.
This is exactly the
angular momentum
of that Jth mass in the
center of mass frame,
and when we total all of
this up, we have R cross
and total V plus LCM.
Now what this first term is,
if you treated the whole object
as a point mass, M total, moving
with V, and here's our point P
and there's R, this
is just what we
call the translational
angular momentum.
It's treating the whole
system as a point-like mass,
and just calculate
moving with speed V,
and that's just the
angular momentum.
We've called this V.
And this piece is the angular
momentum about center of mass.
So sometimes, we can think
of the angular momentum
as corresponding
to a translational,
it has to do with the
actual orbit of the object.
You could call this
orbital angular momentum.
And this is the fact that
the object is rotating.
You could think of this as
the spin angular momentum
about the center of mass.
This is the same
type of decomposition
that we saw with kinetic energy.
There was a translational
component of kinetic energy
and a rotational component
of kinetic energy.
This is the analogous case for
angular momentum about a point
P.